[Music]
Donald Duck's real voice is actually the
result of a very inventive
voice box when he does have that in his
voice box then you hear my beautiful
dulcet tones emit from his bill Uncle
Scrooge is in trouble and it's up to us
to help it Wow he sounds so normal it
was a lot of fun kind of figuring out
how far he pushes things and like I
don't know I've never hadn't done an
animated thing quite like this like
what's he saying when he's saying all
those things you can't understand we're
gonna work in a lot of rassa Fresa and
it'll be it'll be perfect launchpad head
up the air attack to draw her attention
do you think you can crash into the bin
you're gonna just have fun with hearing
and finally speak in a way that's you
know completely different than they've
experienced him before we'll stay here
and out of danger and he takes his power
in this you know he doesn't just have a
voice he like he has a locution and he
really you know says word selections
very careful do you understand yes it
was a lot of fun it's always fun to do
something new and you know voicing
Donald Duck was definitely something
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]